nothing worse than a sticky zipper  I appreciate that you're gonna dream  yourself to death son you gotta live in  the real world  what brings you to two exclusive  that young lady is not what she's seen  I'm afraid she's not very stable I'm not  crazy  she's not your plaything don't go messin  with her  [Music]  Billy you know what the word Tuscaloosa  means it's a new time now you need the  part of the problem be part of the  solution  I'll fix it and make you respectable I  believe in coming to an understanding  [Music]  Tuscaloosa is why powerfully and they  want to keep it that way  I think your daddy's on to us  [Music]  you don't have to figure out what side  line you stand on  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you crazy one crazy about me  then go one true path and that's the one  you want  [Music]  you